et
[Musique]
à new york c'est une réalité difficile à
ignorer
l'eau a toujours fait partie de
l'histoire de la ville
pour le meilleur et pour le pire
tout le monde ici se souvient encore des
ravages causés par l'ouragan szendy le
coeur financier de la ville n'a pas été
épargné l'eau s'est invitée jusque dans
le métro
c'est dans ce quartier que travail luis
ironiquement son organisme fait la
promotion d'une meilleure adaptation des
berges
depuis quelques années il constate que
les mentalités ont évolué à new york
chaque lapin terre vaut son pesant d'or
pas question de s'éloigner de l'eau mais
il faut se protéger des inondations
terrain surélevé mur entouré de
végétation et changements s'opèrent dans
la construction de grands projets
immobiliers en se promenant dans
certaines zones inondables comme ici
dans le secteur financier de manhattan
on constate que certains édifices
récents se sont adaptés
cet hôtel par exemple à installer cette
porte qui peut être utilisé pour les
évacuations en cas d'inondation dans cet
édifice comme bien d'autres dans le
quartier les systèmes de chauffage et de
climatisation ne sont pas au sous sol
mais dans le haut de l'édifice comme
l'exigé le code du bâtiment mais pour se
protéger la ville de new york ne peut
pas uniquement compter sur les efforts
du privé
il est à trois millions d'habitants qui
sont dans des zones inondables
au moins une fois chaque 100 ans le défi
est majeur pour l'affronter la ville a
récemment présenté un plan jugé
audacieux mais nécessaire des barrages
mur
les propositions sont nombreuses et
variées sur la east river la ville
entend par exemple prolonger certaines
sections des berges de 15 jusqu'à 150
mètres 28 pages sur la pointe de
manhattan sera en partie surélevée et
comme cela avait déjà été proposé dans
le passé
une barrière naturelle y sera installée
ici c'est toute une zone qu'on a gagné à
la mer est maintenant l'idée c'est
refaire une protection naturelle qu'on y
avait au début une zone de marais zone
avec une digue de protection mais à la
fois c'est dit que seraient utilisables
et ce serait des espaces verts urbains
ces projets concentrés à manhattan
s'échelonneront sur plusieurs années
mais déjà il soulève des critiques
croient qu'on mystro sur une zone très
vulnérable inquiets
vous savez la crise financière et il
faudrait essayer de répondre tous ces
projets puis il ya le coût faramineux 10
milliards de dollars pour atteindre son
but la très démocrate ville de new york
n'a donc pas d'autre choix que de tendre
la main à l'administration républicaine
de dans notre choix la question demeure
pour compléter sa transformation new
york at elle les moyens de ses ambitions
il cira fait d'oublier auclair
radio-canada new york